c'est une route tenu par les forces du
craignait mais pour combien de temps
encore les troupes russes se rapprochent
d'odessa et pour l'atteindre elle
concentre depuis plusieurs jours leurs
frappes sur cette ville vers où
nicolas if cinq cent mille habitants et
de nombreux quartiers populaires plongée
du jour au lendemain dans la guerre
la vie de valentina et de son immeuble
tranquille a basculé mardi soir
à 4 heures du matin j'ai entendu l'avion
russe arrivée de là bas il avisé
l'immeuble juste là moi j'habite au
quatrième étage
heureusement personne n'est mort
la bombe n'a pas explosé mais elle a
éventré l'immeuble est traumatisé ses
occupants qui vivent désormais au rythme
des détonations
dans cette ville portuaire russophone
l'invasion russe est particulièrement
vécu comme une trahison oui à tout moi
je parle russe comme eux je ne comprends
pas pourquoi les russes nous attaquent
pourquoi chercher à nous blesser sur un
astre aurait le soir tombe
les grondements des combats reprennent
au loin à la périphérie
pour irina la retraitée plus question de
rester dormir chez elle
elle descend rejoindre le reste des
habitants terrés dans la cave
condamnées à attendre chacun relié à la
surface du monde par son téléphone et
irina né en russie s'adresse à la dmr
petit monsieur rappelez-vous trou
laissez nous vivre une vie normale
car nous n'arrivons plus à respirer à
cause de vos bombes vous n'aviez pas
pitié de vos soldats mais ayez pitié de
nous ça suffit
dans le sombre labyrinthe où elle n'est
plus qu'une ombre irina nous conduit
vers une autre salle le sort de ceux qui
se sont installés là l'inquiète beaucoup
deux soeurs et leurs quatre jeunes
enfants dont un bébé de deux semaines
vyacheslav
le petit garçon est né deux jours avant
le début de la guerre il n'a
pratiquement jamais vu la lumière
marina sa mère vit la peur au ventre
surtout depuis le bombardement de
l'hôpital pédiatrique de mario paul en
hausse font maintenant qu'il vise aussi
les enfants on n'a pas le choix soit on
reste ici dans la cave soit on risque
notre vie au cinquième on ne peut pas
courir avec les enfants s'il ya une
nouvelle alerte à la bombe les forces
russes sont aux portes de la ville mais
la résistance ukrainienne est plus
importante que prévu les habitants de
cet immeuble savent que cette vie
souterraine qu'ils se sont organisés va
certainement s'installer dans la durée